im jahr 2015 berichtete länderspiegel
über diese schmucke brücke in mainz
gebaut wurde sie für den busverkehr zum
uni gelände
doch die brücke ende direkt im acker
busse können über das 3,4 millionen euro
teure prachtstück gar nicht drüber
fahren
die stadt hatte schlicht vergessen die
nötigen baugrundstücke zu kaufen damit
die busse weiter fahren können deshalb
wieder ein super beispiel dafür wie man
eine planung in den sand setzen kann
ruhig mal ein bisschen früher
einschalten sollen doch sage niemand die
landeshauptstadt sei nicht lernfähig
nach vier jahren ist es tatsächlich
gelungen die grundstücke zu kaufen um
die bus trasse zu bauen noch in diesem
jahr so der plan soll hier der verkehr
rollen mal sehen ob's klappt in
sonthofen im allgäu haben die ampel
frauen ein juristisches problem weil sie
keine staatlich anerkanntes lichtsignal
sind sollten sie im herbst wieder weg
oder weiblich doch zwei tage nach
ausstrahlung des hammers der woche naht
die rettung die grüne ampel frau und
ihre rote schwester dürfen bis auf
weiteres den verkehr regeln
erst wenn die kreuzung umgebaut wird
sollen wieder ampelmännchen den job
übernehmen
ärger gab es auch beim bau einer
straßenbahn trasse in der oskar straße
in dresden hat die landesdirektion
sachsen bei der planung böse geschlampt
die umweltverträglichkeitsprüfung war
fehlerhaft 2017 gab es deshalb einen
gerichtlichen baustopp eine eingefrorene
baustelle mitten im wohngebiet erst seit
kurzem geht es wieder weiter
es ist lästig aber nicht nur wegen der
kosten sondern einfach wegen der langen
dauer und den ganzen umständen dass die
umleitung und die baustelle aufhört das
hätte mit sicherheit vermieden werden
können wenn ordentlich geplant worden
wäre
die zwangspause kostet die steuerzahler
satte 5 millionen euro zumindest liegen
inzwischen schon ein paar schienen im
sommer soll die oscar straße dann
endlich fertig sein
200 kilometer weiter nördlich im
brandenburgischen teltow wollte man sich
diesen modernen yachthafen können
doch auf dem grundstück wurden unmengen
von altlasten gefunden deshalb ging bei
dem projekt jahrelang nichts voran im
mai 2016 nach zwei jahren bauzeit sah
das ganze noch so aus von den
hochtrabenden plänen war nichts zu sehen
dafür stiegen die kosten inzwischen von
fünf millionen euro auf unglaubliche 14
6 millionen davon hier die ich kenne
möchten diesen haben brauchen diesen
haben wir haben auch alle keine jagd
auch heute ist von dem hochglanz konzept
marina teltow nicht viel zu erkennen ein
ausgelagertes hafenbecken und ein
parkplatz das ist die trübe realität
nach langer suche will die stadt nun
plötzlich nächste woche einen betreiber
für ihr millionengrab präsentieren die
steuerzahler in teltow kann nur hoffen
dass das jetzt tatsächlich die lösung
ist diese extravagante haltestelle in
krefeld haben wir schon mehrfach besucht
das problem in das 3,2 millionen euro
objekt regnet es rein glasscheiben
fehlen andere sind gerissen aus
sicherheitsgründen sind ganze bereiche
abgesperrt
diese dachkonstruktion bietet keinerlei
regenschutz bei regenwetter alles kein
problem hieß es am anfang und
tatsächlich wird die kaputte scheibe
ersetzt aber zu früh gefreut bei den
reparaturarbeiten gehen nebenan die
nächsten scheiben zu bruch
für die krefelder bleibt ihre
haltestelle ein dauerärgernis
die werden nie fertig werden ja das
hätte ich ihnen jetzt schon sagen die
stadt krefeld hat uns versprochen dass
sie dran bleibt wir auch bei unserer
lieblings haltestelle am niederrhein
schauen wir auf jeden fall wieder vorbei